[موسيقى]
والى المزيد من الصور التي تصلنا من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذه الصوره من
واشنطن
لتجمد المياه هناك طبعا ليست واشنطن وحدها
هي التي تشهد هذه الاحوال الاحوال الطقس
البروده الرياح الثلوج الامطار ولكن
العديد من الولايات خاصه في الشرق وولايات
وسط الغرب ورغمى كل ذلك كانت الارصاد
الجويه اتوقعت ان يتحسن الطقس في هذه
الولايات بعد ايام من البرد القارس نتيجه
العاصفه التي وصفت بعاصفه القرن والتي
اودت بحياه اكثر من 50 شخصا على الاقل
واحدث فوضى كبرى في حركه السفر خلال عطل
اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه ونتابع واياكم
هذه الصور اذا التي تريدونا من واشنطن
اضافه الى جانب اخر من الصوره في همم في
ولا وورك اضافه الى الصوره الاخرى من داخل
احد مطارات لوس انجلوس اذا العديد من
المناطق كانت لا تزال تحت تاثير العاصفه
خاصه في بافلو في نيويورك مع تساقط كثيف
همم
للثلوج والعثور على جثث في داخل بعض
السيارات وتحت الثلوج مع تفقد عناصر
الاغاثه المزيد من السيارات بحثا عن ناجين
اذن هذه البحيره هي البحيره المطله على
نصب بواسطه
تجمدت مياه هذه البحيره وهذه صور خاصه بها
جره عاصفه
القرن كثر عاده ما يلجاؤنا الى التزلج على
مياه البحيرات
في الغرب عندما تتجمد في فصل الشتاء نتيجه
البروده
القارصه كما يح الان اذا في العاصمه
الامريكيه وفي عدد من الولايات الامريكيه
الاخرى اذا كانت الارصاد تحدثت عن تحسن
احوال الطقس في الايام المقبله ولكن ضلت
الدعوات لامكانيه همم او الدعوات للحذر من
السفر الى بعض المناطق هناك بسبب هذه
الاحوال الجويه نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي قبل
ان نتابع
[موسيقى]
نتابع واياكم هذه الصور التي تصلنا من
البحيره المطله على نصب لينكولنبي واشنطن
رائع عاصفه القرن طبعا عدد الوفيات كان
ارتفع كما قلنا الى 50 على الاقل طبعا
معظم هذه الحالات هي حوادث الطرق
بالمناسبه كما تريد اخبار اضافه همم الى
تصريحات من المسؤولين الامريكيين ده مثلا
رئيس بلديه بافلو بايرن براون تحدث همم عن
همم امكانيه ارتفاع او توقع ارتفاع العدد
لسوء الحظ وكما قال وهمم بطبيعه الحال همم
يعني همم لا احد همم يتمنى ذلك ولكن هذا
ما تقوله الاخبار همم شلل لمده خمسه ايام
خاصه في
البصل التي نشاهدها في الجزء الاوسط من
هذه الشاشه امامكم من شاشتنا امامكم وكان
من المتوقع ان يتساقط المزيد من الثلوج
لهذا اليوم حاكمه ولايه نيويورك كيف هوشول
قالت ان هذه عاصفه هي اشبه
او الوضع بعد العاصفه اشبه بمنطقه حرب
مؤكده انها عاصفه القرنب كان ركاب وبعض
سكان من الفرين من منازلهم شديده البروده
حسن على الطرق السريعه مع تعذر التدخل
لانقاذهم لان فرق الطوارئ والانقاذ لم يعد
بامكانها طبعا تحمل همم يعني لم يعد لديها
طاقه استيعابيه همم للحجم وهول ما حدث
قالت عائله احدى سكان بافلو انها توفيت في
سيارتها وهي اندل تايلور البالغه من العمر
اثنتين و20 سنه فقط بعد ان علقت في طريقها
من المنزل الى العمل اذا هذا يعني ابرز ما
لياتينا من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
حتى الان بخصوص عاصفه القرن هذه العواصف
التي ادت الى الغاء نحو 20,000 رحله جويه
في الايام الاخيره بينها نحو اربعه الاف
وسبعمائه رحله الثلاثاء وفق موقع التتبع
المتخصص فلايت اور